parfait merci à nu et dans les
propositions concrètes donc c'est
effectivement de renforcer les crédits
au fisac
le fonds d'intervention de soutien à
l'artisanat et au commerce qui ont été
considérablement réduits par madame
pinel et puis de mettre en place un
certain nombre de dispositifs dont de
rembourser les crédits pour la detr qui
ont été là aussi considérablement réduit
je vais ensuite passé la parole à henri
bies pierre président de la commission
gestion du territoire à la fnsea
oui merci merci bonjour à toutes et à
tous je suis agriculteur dans les
pyrénées pratique dans la partie
béarnaise des pratiques puisque on ne
manquera pas de vous poser la question
d'où est-ce que je viens je souscris
complètement aux propos qui vient d'être
tenus sur le constat sur la proportion
des habitants qui habitent ces zones
rurales
nous avons à la ffsa et je suis aussi co
responsable avec daniel prieur qui
connaissait bien d'un groupe qui
s'appelle le groupe au monde rural qui
réunit aussi une vingtaine
d'organisations à la fois d'élus et de
socioprofessionnels qui on se soucie de
l'avenir du monde rural
alors je dirais que il n'y a pas
beaucoup de propositions nouvelles
affaires pour accompagner le monde rural
je crois que maintenant il faut vraiment
décidés décrété j'ai lu les mots de plan
marshall décrété le jour où on commence
à mettre en oeuvre
je il ya un point particulier sur lequel
vraiment on appris en retard c'est sur
le numérique et la téléphonie mobile
fait honnêtement il ya eu des plans et
des plans depuis des années et des
années
il faut des moyens certes conséquent
mais cette fracture numérique est en
train de mettre hors jeu la partie des
territoires euros non équipés imaginez
qu'aujourd'hui on demande aux
agriculteurs
on a l'ambition d'être à 100% de
déclaration pac via telepac territoire
non couverts à les télécharger des fonds
de cartes sur cannes vous n'avez pas le
haut débit c'est impossible c'est
impossible donc aujourd'hui l'accès aux
services publics voilà que les bureaux
de postes disparaissent que les services
publics disparaissent
oui vous avez le remplacement vous
pouvez tout consulter sur mon.service
public.fr si vous n'êtes pas desservi
par un bon réseau numérique encore une
fois
vous êtes out je parle du métier
d'agriculteur avec des coopératives qui
proposent de plus en plus de services de
commande en ligne de vente du maïs des
céréales de profiter des cours mondiaux
tout ça aussi consultables par internet
si vous n'avez pas encore une fois cet
axe-là en haut débit
vous êtes là aussi out vous attendez
trois jours que le facteur vous porte la
lettre pour dire que le maïs a augmenté
et qu'on pouvait vendre au delà de notre
métier je veux parler aussi des familles
parce que c'est un mot aussi enfin voilà
que j'ai pas beaucoup entendu mais dans
le milieu rural
il ya des hommes et des femmes est un
entrepreneur il ya aussi leurs familles
car vous avez un enfant de 12 13 14 ans
qui rentrent au collège qui un 6e 5e 4e
a dit le professeur dit ça tirait
consulter sur internet où tu pourra
regarder ton cahier de texte sur
internet
là aussi et bien vos enfants quand vous
habitez un milieu rural quand il se
retrouve à la ville ou à la vie de
bourges où existe le collège ou le lycée
eh bien il se trouve par rapport à ses
copains complètement là aussi démuni
vis-à-vis de tout un certain nombre de
services et on trouve naturel professeur
de dire vous avez accès à sa part
internet voilà donc pensons vraiment
cette fracture numérique
mettons les moyens méthodes le paquet
j'ai entendu parler de 2022 pour couvrir
le territoire et bien 2022 on peut vous
dire que les gens qui habitent un
territoire rural que vous avez cités il
sera moitié moins nombreux ils seront
moins nombreux à terme d'agriculture
parle diversification vous montez gîte
rural
si vous mentez si vous mettez pas sur le
site que vous avez accès à internet avec
du wifi mais c'est pas la peine les gens
ne viennent pas a fait l'expérience
allait en zone rurale
au jour d'aujourd'hui a exactement ce
smartphone dans la poche le matin ou les
consulter votre droit local c'est pas
possible donc vraiment s'il ya une
grande priorité c'est celle vraiment de
cette couverture numérique émirats le
jeune insisterait presque que sur ce
sujet je renforcerai les propos que tu
étais didier sur quatre donnaient un
milieu rural on a besoin d'avoir accès à
l'école on a besoin d'avoir la saleté on
a parlé de la santé humaine mais il ya
aussi la santé animale les vétérinaires
en milieu rural il faut comme les
toubibs ils vont en ville pour soigner
les chiens les chats ou erratique au
havre à de vraies difficultés à
maintenir de l'élevage bovin et ovin
dans les campagnes sont là aussi on n'a
pas le même effort vis-à-vis des
terry nerfs que celui qu'on est en train
d'imaginer pour les docteurs en leur
donnant des compléments de rémunération
pour les inciter à faire au moins une
partie de la carrière en milieu rural et
pour avoir ces services là bien sûr
qu'on va pas demander à ce que chaque
cas de tonnes à chaque zone y ait des
hôpitaux etc
donc on a deux solutions si on peut pas
rapprocher ses services la santé
éducation culture des zones rurales au
moins qu'on rapproche et je terminerai
là dessus les zones rurales de ces
services-là via les voies de
communication quand vous dites il faut
qu'on soit 32 minutes d'un hôpital soit
il ya une au moins est en route et
auquel cas il faut naître qu'avec km
soyez une très bonne route et à ce
moment là où habite à 5,4 kilomètres
parce que les 30 minutes vous les faites
la même manière donc il ya un
investissement affaire-là aussi sur les
infrastructures en milieu rural qui
sinon apporteront là aussi une vraie
fracture entre les gens qui habitent en
ville avec tous les moyens de transport
et les plus écologiques au possible et
les gens milieu rural a quitté à qui on
dire à chaque fois que vous venez à la
ville vous polluez donc restez chez vous
ils n'y resteront pas ils viendront la
ville pour la merci parfait merci